the Joe Rogan experience Amanda noon
isn't random II is uh that's a fight
that people are not talking about enough
the random E is good she's super
technical Mary when she refused to fight
cyber yeah us give up the belt ice noise
now you can kiss this ass interested
dude Volken off ski verse Matt's always
a good [ __ ] fight you ever see Vulcan
on ski when he's 240 past fantastic
rugby player there's five sides of him
to 40 he's from Izzy same camp yes he's
an animal and Max look away max how a
consensus greatest featherweight of all
time yeah of all time
he's the best beat the [ __ ] out of Aldo
twice wife beat the [ __ ] out of Ortega
that's not the main event no keep going
one more John job Oh tomorrow Oman and
Colby Covington no John Jones is the
what is that which one is he Jerry is
that the other Vegas one host is right
it's February
that's right Houston oh come on Monica
will be coming to give me that again let
me see that again
let's go back to Greece Monaco be
covered in good luck calling that was
there I don't know both both their
styles are very similar the only
difference on that you can really see
neither guys ever been taking down a
fight ever but uh I would give the
finishing power to kymaro's man I would
as well he has some power
he does have some power how about Colby
with Robbie Lawler oh yeah just Alps
truck um yeah yeah insane well not only
that puts a pace on that you just can't
handle you can't handle it but if
anybody can handle it it's that guy cuz
think about it loosely did Woodley yeah
takedown defense a hundred percent
tomorrow who's maan a hundred problem
[ __ ] is Kobe 78 who took him down they
won't take him down maybe his first
fight didn't get submitted he had a
broken rib took a fight early in his
career injured I think to get into the
UFC really in losses got submitted I
want to say it was his first fight go to
Kobe Covington's first fight in the
Octagon that's what they're gonna do
Woodley Leon Edwards
just hit me that's a tough fight tough
fight guys
good fight very good fight what does it
guillotine who in first fight in the UFC
no he was I made him eight in one who
are you talking about in the UFC eight
and one in the UFC how many fights in
was it really who did it yeah burly
Alvis that's right that was the fight
that he got injured Worley Alva's was a
beast yeah he's kind of falling off but
he was on he was a beast but did I'm
assuming Coby shot in while Kobe went
into that fight with a fucked-up rib I
know that for a fact but did he shoot in
get guillotine it make sense I don't
remember how the [ __ ] do you think no he
was he was hurt I know for sure and then
who did he fight after that because let
me tell you the fight that made him put
on this act she'll pop his his record it
was quick enough in his first round Oh
was yeah well he was [ __ ] up I know
for sure he was [ __ ] up going on that
fight that was if I didn't want to take
coz him in jail are close and she was
like you need come up with a stick dude
do you think so 100% okay let me see
make that a little bigger for my shitty
eyes um I'll scroll up okay there it is
it was I think it was when he was was it
when he was fighting Demian my they
started talking [ __ ] where's that saw
Paulo yep that's exactly that's exactly
so he's fighting Damien paya filthy
animals yeah I called them filthy animal
calling so apparently what was going on
before then was he was not making enough
noise there was no one gave a [ __ ] about
him and you know there in the middle of
contract negotiations and I think they
were threatening to cut him so he says
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] about Demian
Maia and people pay attention they go
okay okay how about this we'll give you
another Brazilian so they give him half
failed dos Anjos he beats the [ __ ] at a
hospital Sonya's and they're like holy
[ __ ] wait a minute here
wait a minute so in doing that he wins
the interim title and then there was a
bunch of shenanigans they wanted him to
fight in Madison Square Garden he said
look I can't fight back to back that
quickly these are a hard-ass camp so
they stripped them a lot of [ __ ] going a
lot of [ __ ] so then they bring it back
against Robbie Lawler big comeback fight
Robbie Lawler is a murderer
yeah big fight on ESPN and he just runs
him over man runs him over like Robbie
never got air he never got air I hope we
just stayed on him stayed on me look at
his record right the last six all five
lasts five all decisions so it's like if
you're like any guy all this get you
doesn't finish but what he's doing it
guys like Demian Maia and dos Anjos and
Robbie Lawler was so fun to watch he's
breaking dudes he's this is crazy
October of 2017 so it's basically two
years old this act and I can't leave I
told I can't wait for him to drop it I
can't wait for him to drop it once it
becomes a champ and tell all there's no
need you know why he didn't keep it
going because he has he wants to go to
WWE yeah it's his thing cuz smart not
matters like I won't go w if he becomes
a champ and then goes to WWE and they
put them on all the steroids why not and
then get them up to about 240 keep the
hat keep going make bank shake it yeah
tell him I'm gonna show you [ __ ] how
to really fight fantast how about him
versus Lesnar's a heel dude you'll see
that you'll see that let's go fight a
little dude the other day [ __ ] crazy
that's what he wants to do hey why not
man you can make money you know at a
certain point time you gotta go you know
he accomplished a lot he's accomplished
a lot sent
if he decides if he beats Usman he's
they count me in a parlous and how am I
gonna keep this guy cuz everybody knows
fighting you know it's a finite window
like everybody gonna do next and nobody
knows what his body's like right now as
far as injuries and how many guys do you
know that are in camp that have one
fucked-up knee or a weird shoulder or
the neck keeps [ __ ] when especially
for his skill set that motor and that
grind like he's a grinder so you gotta
have it all man I would like to watch
his strength and conditioning workout
cuz it must be [ __ ] insane it must be
insane cuz even Jorge Maz and all off
record on stalking him I go what do you
think about Kobe as we've trained
together he goes I've never seen a motor
like that ever in my life he's a mother
he can go man he can go he can go he put
it on Robbie Lara like I never seen
anybody put it on crazy the pace the
pace was just insane he just never gave
him any air just kept on bang bang bang
and I go I go will you
I go you go in 50 60 % he goes yeah
about 50 60 % yeah just volume just
never never throw in full blast to
staying on you Harry Nate Nick deals
this guy started that longing started it
Nick started if you go back to watch his
fight with Frank Shamrock he just never
gave Frank Shamrock any breaks just
exploding volume until he gets you hurt
then he starts ripping to the body
taking to the body and he starts letting
you know I'm not even a little tired
[ __ ] and you're exhausted he starts
putting on you
[Applause]